I don't make things for museums
or for art collectors.
And if you think that what I'm
saying is bullshit, immediately
change the channel and do something
else.
Do you want to build a rocket ship
but don't have the deep pockets
of Jeff Bezos, Elon Musk
or Richard Branson?
You might want to turn to the Rocket
Factory, a trans dimensional
manufacturing plant created by
artist Tom Sachs, in which
you can build and own a personalized
rocket in both the physical and
virtual world.
The project is one of the most
inventive uses of NFTs,
a groundbreaking technology that
makes digital items one of a kind.
By giving them a unique code that
can't be duplicated or forged.
The rocket factory builds on
previous themes in sex work,
such as creating painstakingly
realistic reproductions of familiar
objects and in a nod
to Andy Warhol referencing
popular brands and companies
long obsessed with spaceflight.
He's also created three different
space program installations,
each of which contemplates what it
means to fly to the Moon, Mars
and beyond.
Sachs' art makes use of the new
form of digital commons called the
blockchain, which is the shared
public database that makes it
possible to prove that you and
you alone own an NFT.
Of the Metaverse, the 3D
virtual world where some believe
a great deal of human interaction
will soon be migrating and
of our persistent longing for a
new frontier.
All of which are characteristics
of what is often called Web
3.0, the next
phase in the evolution of the
internet.
Reason spoke with Sachs in his
Manhattan studio about the role of
psychedelics in his creative
process, how the internet has
radically flattened and improved
the relationship between artist and
audience, and why his meticulously
handcrafted NFT rockets
can be just as exciting,
innovative and inspiring
as the ones made by Bezos,
Musk and Branson.
Tom Sachs, thanks for talking to
Reason.